I am generals born I'm Sudbury district
councillor for the East Ward I am also
deputy leader at Weber and I'm cabinet
member for housing my name is Jill
Wilshire I am cabinet member for housing
district councilmember for bactin and
old Newton with that with and Gipping
when I was given the portfolio for
housing
I obviously event started to really
realize the importance of providing
affordable homes in our district and
beyond
my husband would used to be a developer
when he was alive so I've always had
this interest in housing and I was quite
very honored to be asked to be the
cabinet member for housing for mid
Suffolk the cost of buying a home in
Weber is 11 times the level of a
person's salary which is completely an
athlete out of most people's reach so
it's even more important that we do
provide those affordable homes we need
more houses in this Suffolk because
there are a lot of younger people
wanting to stay in this Suffolk and they
are they can't afford to live here
because the the cost of of private
housing is so expensive so we are trying
to build more affordable houses so that
they can stay in the and near their
relatives and stay in the county we have
got good at plans for the needs and
markets at HQ site we are hopefully
going to build about 48 houses within
the mid Needham market middle school
most of them are a lot of them being
affordable housing we need to ensure
that we're providing new homes in the
right places for the right people of the
right type we've already provided 12 in
Lebanon 15 in glimpse furred and we've
now bought six off-site in Sudbury eight
off plan in radan another 27 off plan in
Holbrook and there's more coming through
the pipeline including angel Hall Angel
Court in Hadley so if you are interested
in a Community Land Trust or any other
initiatives that are coming forward from
both Weber and central government please
contact
Liz Ling hi I'm Elizabeth Ling I'm
community housing enabling officer for
baby district council and mid Suffolk
District Council you can contact me on
Elizabeth dot Ling at Baber mid Suffolk
gov dot UK